-Alright, guys. It is time for
"Tonight Show Hashtags."
Here we go.
-♪ Hashtags ♪
♪ Hashtags ♪
-We do this thing every week
where I send out a hashtag
and I ask you guys to respond to
that topic.
So since my show "That's My Jam"
is premiering next week, I went
on Twitter and sent out
the #ThatsMyJam.
And I asked you guys to send in
some funny or weird things that
you like to do,
things that are your jam.
Within minutes it was a trending
topic in the U.S.,
so thank you for playing along.
[ Cheers and applause ]
So now I thought I'd share some
of my favorite #ThatsMyJam
tweets from you guys.
Here we go.
This first one's from
@71meliwoe. She says...
[ Cheers and applause ]
I do that. That's my jam.
I do it too.
"Moo, moo, moo."
[ Laughter ]
This one's from @jaco0721.
-Mm!
-They say...
[ Cheers and applause ]
This one's from
@explaurenaround. She says...
[ Laughter and applause ]
-Nice.
-This one's from @ramandwildcat.
She says...
[ Laughter ]
What?
-That's your jam?
-That's their jam.
This one's from
@pierrelafrance0. He says...
[ Cheers and applause ]
That is our jam.
We all have that.
-We all got that.
-This one's from @djtheoldman.
He says...
[ Cheers and applause ]
Take the W. A win's a win.
This one's from @ubiquitousbdog.
They say...
[ Laughter and applause ]
"Speak. Speak.
Habla. Habla."
Last one from @notloggedin.
She says...
[ Cheers and applause ]
That's correct!
There you have it. Those are
"Tonight Show Hashtags."
To check out more of
our favorites,
go to tonightshow.com/hashtags.
"That's My Jam" Tuesday night,
10:00 p.m.
We'll be right back with
Brendan Fraser. Come on back.